let's add one more feature of romance
verbs to persons tenses and aspects it's
called mood so far the verbs we've met
gave us information about who performed
in action and when they were all
matter-of-fact about it Cantus for you
seeing fantasti for you saying that kind
of thing
we might even say that they all indicate
who does what they're in the indicative
mood plain statements and questions have
indicative verbs whatever the tense can
toss in Latinos can toss in Latino such
verbs ask for or provide information in
a vanilla way did this happen yes that
happened is it yes it is these kinds of
statements account for so much of what
we say and write including most of my
narration what if the mood isn't so
indicative
Latin and romance verbs also marked
actions as possibly contrary to fact
were not necessarily the case this is
useful when you want hope fear doubt
need or recommend an action continuing
with my apparent fondness for the verb
can Tata compare one indicative form
cantamos to a subjunctive vodka temos as
in spirit quo continues she hopes that
we sing it's a matter of fact that she
does hope so that's in the indicative
but we may or may not actually sing so
this second verb is in the subjunctive I
slit a little word quoting there it's
the word for that in Latin and it
becomes something like gay in nearly
every Romance language we use care to
connect the subjunctive verb to the verb
that triggers the subjunctive as in hope
that want that need that recommend that
and so on so Vedic quote is followed by
an indicative with it quick on thumbs
but spirit quote by a subjunctive spirit
quote and demos notice the thematic
vowel it switches this is a key feature
that distinguishes indicative and
subjunctive
that's present-tense subjunctive stuff
we can also use a past subjunctive this
past or imperfect subjunctive is
especially useful in hypotheticals see
can't a say
Iberian languages also developed a
future subjunctive for uncertain future
actions like when I will sing or if I
will sing which remains in Portuguese
but not Spanish
when do cantata SHhhh
Western Romance languages have
conditional endings that work a lot like
the future indicative endings that
attached the verb for have to the end of
an infinitive these are fractions
someone would do the imperfect of have
is used in France in Iberia the
preterite of have is used in Italy other
languages including Romanian and
Sardinian build phrases or used the
imperfect indicative to get the same
conditional meaning imperatives issue a
command the basic idea is simple take
the verb add the thematic valve Kanta be
dead some common verbs are even shorter
beak
there are also plural forms for ordering
around a group of people than that they
be dating a negative command uses the
subjunctive in Iberia non Cantus the
infinitive is used in Italy non-kin
tarde in languages that use third-person
forms to address you politely like
cantata for both sings and you sir madam
sing the subjunctive comes back into
play for both positive and negative
commands content
content person number tense aspect mood
you now have all the basic features of
romance verb endings next time it's on
to helping verbs notably evading to have
an ascetic to be